Antes de empezar este video tengo que
haceros 2 advertencias:
la primera es que vamos a hacer
spoilers de la serie Narcos. Aunque
tratándose de una serie que relata un
acontecimiento histórico
no creo que sea ningún problema, pero
bueno, yo por si acaso ahí os lo dejo.
La segunda, es que vamos a hablar del
narcotráfico, que se trata de un tema
muy opaco y donde casi toda la
información que se puede encontrar es
incompleta y en cualquier momento pueden
aparecer nuevos hallazgos policiales que
invaliden los conocimientos previos.
Dicho esto, vamos a empezar.
Colombia, es conocido como el país de los mil
ritmos, el lugar donde se cultiva el
mejor café del mundo y donde han nacido
todos esos artistas colombianos que le
gustan a tu novia.
Sin embargo, lo que ha hecho que Colombia
sea tristemente famosa es este señor de
aquí: - "soy Pablo Emilio Escobar Gaviria".
- "haciendo negocios así que, pues fresco".
El rey de la cocaína, el hombre que
creó un negocio tan peligroso como
rentable. A finales de los años 80,
Pablo Escobar o Pablo como le conocen
sus vecinos de Medellín, controlaba
nada menos que el 90% de la cocaína
que se vendía en todo el planeta.
De repente, Medellín, que es una ciudad de
Colombia con unos dos millones de
habitantes se convirtió en el Hollywood
de la cocaína. Y como todos ya sabéis
el 1 de diciembre de 1993
Pablo Escobar murió en un tiroteo a
manos de la policía colombiana.
Ahora, la pregunta es ¿qué pasa después?
¿Quién recuperó el testigos que había
dejado Pablo Escobar? y lo que es más
importante ¿Todavía existe tráfico de
cocaína en Colombia?
Hoy vamos a responder a esa pregunta, y
lo vamos a hacer de la mano de un hombre
que vive en las mismas calles que en su
día tránsito el mismísimo Pablo Escobar.
Porque sí amigos de VisualPolitik,
hoy tenemos al músico más talentoso
de todo Medellín, al sex symbol
paisa, al hombre que compuso la música
que está sonando ahora mismo:
efectivamente, estamos hablando de Rick
Vallejo: - "Hola, Fonseca y un abrazo
a todos los subscriptores de VisualPolitik,
Tal y como dices, Pablo Escobar
es toda una leyenda aquí, en la ciudad
de Medellín. Incluso llegó a construir su propio barrio
llamado barrio pablo escobar,
ahora oficialmente conocido como "Medellín Sin Tugurios".
Y pese a todos sus crímenes y atentados
terroristas todavía puedes ver
pelados, ósea, adolescentes que llamamos acá,
queriendo ser como él, que aspiran a llegar a ser
como el patron, como Pablo Escobar.
Pero antes de hablar de la era post
Pablo Escobar
tenemos que hablar de la cocaína. Si
normalmente decimos que el petróleo es
el oro negro, la cocaína bien podría
llamarse el oro blanco.
Se trata de las droga ilegal más
consumida en el mundo después de la
marihuana, pero hay una diferencia la
marihuana se puede cultivar en cualquier
lugar del planeta, incluso en el norte de
Europa la policía encuentra muchas
veces plantaciones domésticas de cannabis.
Prácticamente, cualquier persona con
muy poquitos medios puede reproducir
las condiciones climáticas necesarias
para cultivar marihuana.
Sin embargo, la hoja de coca necesita un
hábitat muy específico.
Tan específico que solamente se
puede cultivar en unas poquitos países,
principalmente Colombia, Perú y Bolivia.
En otras palabras, hay espacio para muy
poquitos proveedores pero sin embargo la
demanda es enorme,
nunca cesa y es a nivel mundial. Y por
eso, el negocio de la cocaína es una de
los más rentables que existen.
Y, precisamente por eso, cuando Pablo
Escobar dejó un espacio vacío en esta
industria no faltaban candidatos para
llenarlo.
Cómo sabéis, Pablo Escobar era el líder del cártel
de Medellín
pero ya incluso antes de su muerte
Medellín no era la única capital de la
coca, también había un grupo de
narcotraficantes muy importantes en esta
otra ciudad que vemos aquí, que se llama
Cali; y que además tiene más o menos la
misma población que Medellín.
- "Mientras Pablo dejó un rastro de cuerpos
a su paso, Calí hizo desaparecer los
problemas con un ejército de abogados y
una montaña de informes judiciales,
el cartel de Medellín era como Miami
piscinas, chicas en biquini,
horteras como un
Cadillac bicolor. El cartel de Calí era
como Nueva York, elegante, fino, sutil.
Podían animar la fiesta durante horas
con cocaína y aún así asegurarse de
que todo el mundo se presentase al
trabajo en Wall Street a la mañana
siguiente. Al principio Medellín y Cali
trabajaron codo con codo,
pero en Colombia cuando hay dinero de
por medio inevitablemente la sangre
corre". Tras la muerte de Pablo Escobar el
cartel de Cali esperaba hacerse con todo
el negocio de Pablo Escobar.
Sin embargo, en su propia ciudad natal, en
Medellín
también había un montón de bandas
pequeñita intentando hacer la misma
operación.
Uno de estos pequeños líderes del
narcotráfico, que por cierto también
aparecen en la serie, era Diego Fernando
Murillo, alias Don Berna.
Cómo ya sabeis, Don Berna ayudó tanto a la policía
colombiana, como a la estadounidense a
acabar con Pablo Escobar.
Incluso, llegó a aliarse con el cartel
de Cali y con un grupo de paramilitares
de extrema derecha llamados "Las
Autodefensas Unidas de Colombia". Con el
rey de la cocaína muerto, el cartel de
Cali se fue por su lado y Don Berna se
quedó en Medellin empezando su
pequeño negocio de exportación de
cocaína.
Además, tenía al grupo de paramilitares
que le podía ayudar a protegerlo. Dicho
de otra forma, las autodefensas unidas de
colombia le proporcionaba la seguridad y
don berna ponía su extenso conocimiento
del mercado y esa metodología que había
aprendido tras años de trabajar con los
socios de pablo escobar.
Así es como nació la llamada Oficina
de Envigado.
Por aquel entonces todos los pequeños narcos de Medellín
luchaban por conseguir el monopolio estatal.
Está calle que puedes ver en Google  Maps
trazaba el límite de las zonas de bandas enemigas.
Entonces, por ejemplo, sí tu cruzabas
esta calles y eras de la Oficina de Envigado
pero la banda de este lado era una banda
enemiga, lo más probables es que te mataran.
Mientras tanto el cartel de Cali utilizaba unos
métodos mucho más sutiles, como se ve en
la serie tanto Gilberto Rodríguez como
su socio el Pacho Herrera eran gente de
clase alta, con contactos entre la clase
política, los abogados y los jueces.
Es más, el propio Gilberto llegó
a donar más de seis millones de dólares
para financiar la campaña electoral de
Ernesto Samper, quien después llegaría
a convertirse nada menos que en
Presidente de Colombia.
Sin embargo, poco importó la corrupción
y el tráfico de influencias.
Tarde o temprano pasó lo inevitable:
El gobierno inició las
gestiones para la expedición de Miguel
Rodríguez Orejuela en la cárcel de
palogordo en girón, santander donde
está recluido el jefe del cartel de
cali".
No podemos decir lo mismo de don berna,
es más, de todos los personajes que han
aparecido en estas dos primeras
temporadas de narcos, don berna es el que
más tiempo ha sido capaz de escapar de
la justicia. Pero esperad un momento
porque ahora es cuando vamos a hablar de
esos personajes que no salen en la serie.
Y preparaos porque hay para rato.
¿Os acordéis que os decía de don berna se
había aliado con un grupo de
paramilitares de extrema derecha para
que protegiera sus operaciones? Pues en
este caso la ideología política
importa.
Las autodefensas unidas de colombia
nacieron con el propósito de combatir
las guerrillas marxista leninista que
estaban en la selva. Y sí en Narcos nos
hablan del m 19 pero sin duda alguna la
más importante de todas ellas es esta:
Decir que las FARC son un
grupo terrorista es quedarse corto: en
algunos momentos llegaron a ser todo
un estado paralelo al gobierno de
Colombia, lo más parecido a lo que las
podemos comparar es a lo que hoy en día
es el DAES o el estado islámico.
Buena parte de lo que es la selva
colombiana estaba bajo el control de
esta guerrilla comunista. Las farc
controlaban a los médicos los
hospitales los profesores las
escuelas incluso llegaban a cobrar sus
propios impuestos. - " Se estima que el grupo
tiene unos 20 mil miembros distribuidos en
24 de las 32 provincias colombiana". Como
podéis imaginar a las farc tampoco les
hacía mucha gracia a los
narcotraficantes. Sí, vale es verdad que
tanto los narcos como los terroristas
tenían a varios enemigos en común, pero
tendréis que reconocerme que la idea de
hacerse millonario vendiendo un producto
en el mercado internacional no es algo
que suene muy y marxista leninista,
precisamente ¿verdad?
Además los secuestros y la extorsión
también puede ser un negocio muy
rentable, y en eso las Farc eran
auténticos maestros.
Si a eso le sumas que don berna y su
oficina de envigado están protegidos
por un grupo de paramilitares
anticomunistas,
está claro que la guerra es inevitable.
- "Todo el sureste del municipio de bojayá hoy
inmerso en estas espesa vegetación y
maleza. Hallá era el punto norte y desde
ahí la guerrilla de las farc lanzaba
los cilindros bomba hacia allá hacia el
otro extremo el municipio". - "El negocio
el negocio. Por mucho dinero que ganara
las Farc con los secuestros
fue muy difícil resistirse a entrar
en el negocio del narcotráfico.
Así que un día, Medinas Caracas, uno de los
comandantes de las Farc decide entrar en el negocio de la coca.
Es un hecho que las
Farc lideran el control de la mayoría de
zonas donde se encuentran las
plantaciones de coca en Colombia.
De hecho, llevan varios años extorsionando a los
cultivadores locales.
Sin embargo, con medina caracas al frente
las farc llegaron a tener sus propias plantaciones
de coca y sus propias redes de distribución.
Estamos ya en el año 2000 y en estos
momentos el clan de cali ya está
totalmente desmantelado.
Sin embargo, la cocaína sigue dando
trabajo a miles de colombianos. Por hacer
un resumen tenemos por un lado a la
oficina de envigado con don berna a la
cabeza y las autodefensas unidas de
colombia protegiéndolo. Por otro lado
tenemos a las Farac y por otro
tenemos a un montón de bandas
criminales independientes a las que
vamos a llamar "las bacrim".
Por cierto, esto que están escuchando es la calle una
canción compuesta e interpretada por mi.
Si les gusta pueden encontrar el link de
mi canal en la descripción.
Y justo en este escenario de
atomización del mercado de la cocaína
colombia elige a un nuevo presidente.
Álvaro Uribe. Uribe había nacido en
medellín y su principal objetivo era
acabar con la violencia que había
diezmado al país y así es como
comienza un período que podríamos
llamar:
Álvaro Uribe estaba dispuesto a acabar con los
guerrilleros, los paramilitares y los
narcos a cualquier coste.
Por eso en el año 2005 el que era su
ministro de defensa Camilo Ospina Bernal
firma la tristemente famosa directiva
029 y ¿por qué se hizo tan tristemente
famosa?  -"La directiva decía literalmente que el
gobierno daría el equivalente a 1.900
dólares a cualquier miembro de la fuerza
pública que diera de baja, que asesinará a
cualquier miembro de la guerrilla o de
las fuerzas paramilitares.
Si en aquel entonces eras un milutar
colombiano y querían ascender rápido en
tu carrera o ganar cierto dinero de más
lo único que tenías que hacer era salir a la caza de los miembros
de los grupos armados.
De repente los muertos en las FARC y
otros  grupos armados ilegales se
empezaron contar por ciento". Pero esperad
momento porque ésto sólo fue el
principio. Encontrar a miembros de las
FARC no es tarea fácil. Sin embargo, la
recompensa que daba el gobierno era
demasiado jugosa. - "fue así los
militares asesinaron a varios civiles inocentes.
Después los vestían con el informe de las
FARC,
los armaban y con estas pruebas
fotos
iban a la oficina correspondiente a cobrar.
Pero esto no paso  ni una ni dos veces. Aquí en colombia matar a falsos
positivos se convirtió en toda una costumbre para todo aquel
beneficiarán herminia dos más para que
que quería ganarse un sobresueldo.
A día de hoy la fiscalía general de la nación tiene más
de tres mil casos de falsos positivos por investigar".
Pero esperan un momento porque si,
es verdad, la política de Uribe fue
extremadamente controvertida, pero hay
algo que le tenemos que reconocer, le
puso las cosas muy complicadas tanto a
las Farc como a los narcos.
Las redadas tanto a los campos de coca
como las redes de distribución
eran continuas. Así que cuando tu
enemigo común mata a los tuyos te
alías hasta con el mismísimo diablo si
hace falta.
- "Las Farc están
presentes en casi todas las zonas donde
se produce coca. En algunos casos estas
plantaciones pertenecen a la oficina de
Envigado o a otras diferentes".
Otras plantaciones están
directamente gestionadas por las Farc.
Allí cultivan y procesan la hoja de coca para que luego los grandes
carteles se encarguen de su distribución a otros
países".
Sin embargo, a diferencia de los tiempos
de pablo escobar los cárteles de
colombia han perdido el monopolio de la
distribución de cocaína.
Por ejemplo, cuando quieren enviar su
mercancía a estados unidos lo hacen a
través de un cartel mafioso mexicano
que coge la cocaína y la transportan
por vía terrestre.
Y para los envíos a europa también
tiene sus conexiones con las mafias
italianas, griegas o albano kosovares,
pero de eso vamos a hablar en otro video.
- "Lo más importante de todo es que aunque
aún existe el tráfico de cocaína,
Medellín se ha vuelto una  ciudad mucho más tranquila.
Aun existen barrios sobre todo
de la periferia donde es mejor no acercarse
porque puede ser un poco peligro, pero
la verdad es que Medellín ha cambiado mucho.
Está PAx mafiosa ha ha permitido que todos los
distintos actores envueltos en el
narcotráfico colombiano ya tengan muy
claras cuáles son sus zonas de
actuación y no interfieran con las de
los demás. Y os preguntaréis qué puede
pasar ahora que las farc están haciendo
un acuerdo de paz con el gobierno
colombiano.
Lo cierto es que podría suponer una
oportunidad para todas esas bacrin que
podrían recuperar todas las áreas de
negocio que ahora están bajo control de
la guerrilla, pero lo cierto es que ahora
todos estos cárteles de
narcotraficantes también quieren
negociar con el gobierno un acuerdo de
paz que sea tan provechoso como el que
están negociando las FARC.
-"Las Farc se presentan como un grupo político,
con su propia ideología política.
Incluso tienen desde hace muchos años un sitio web.
Así que ahora todos estos narcos se preguntan por qué a
ellos sí y a nosotros no. No os olvidéis que
los acuerdos de paz entre el gobierno de
colombia y las farc son muy pero que muy
beneficiosos para los terroristas. Si quereis
entender mejor en qué consistió en
este primer acuerdo de paz que se
sometió a referéndum en colombia y que
se parece mucho a lo que parece que
sería el segundo acuerdo de paz
podéis hacer clic en el video de aquí.
Pero ahora la pregunta es ¿es posible
acabar con el tráfico de cocaína o
cada vez que se acaba con una banda
aparece otra que la sustituye? Podeis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios,
y no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiós al canal para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones, y tampoco olvideis
visitar el canal de mi amigo rick
vallejo:
-"En mi canal encontraran mis canciones propias, casmis versiones de
clásicos
y por supuesto
tutoriales de como tocar guitarra". Y como
siempre, si os ha gustado esté vídeo
darle a like y nos vemos en el próximo
un abrazo y hasta pronto.